ce sont appartient dorénavant au passé
le minitel ctu la nuit dernière pour
tourner cette page de l'histoire
française des télécommunications trois
hommes pendant trente ans ils ont assuré
le bon fonctionnement du réseau
hier soir ils ont veillé à son
extinction alors que le compte à rebours
est lancé
quelques usagers sont encore connectés
85 personnes 85 sur le réseau minitel un
quart d'heure avant la fin à 87,1 23h45
nous sommes le 30 juin 2012
et c'est la fin du minitel 30 ans de
bons et loyaux services
l'internet avant l'heure je vous propose
de voyager dans le temps et de retourner
au début des années 80 la télématique
vous savez et bien c'est le mariage
entre le téléphone la télévision et
l'ordinateur et un mariage finalement
très réussie puisque déjà et bien on
voit apparaître des enfants les nouveau
nés alors les voici
ils vont voir et il est déjà ancienne
nous avons présentée l'annuaire
électronique en quelque sorte de parti
premièrement vous voyez un écran de
télévision sur lequel s'affichent les
renseignements que l'on trouve
habituellement dans la mer et puis un
clavier pour l'interroger
une variante également de ce système
c'est le télé tel cette fois ci c'est
l'écran de votre téléviseur relié un
clavier spécial et sur l'écran doté d'un
viseur apparaîtront différents
renseignements comme par exemple si vous
aimez la bourse les cours de la bourse
ou bien les horreurs de chemin de fer ou
bien les programmes des spectacles 1982
dans les chaumières on voit arriver deux
innovations majeures le téléphone à
touches
parce qu'avant pour téléphoner fallait
faire ça oui je sais c'était un peu long
heureusement il y avait que six chiffres
mais le top du top de ses france des
années 80 en avance sur son temps c'est
l'invention du minitel pour les puristes
médium interactif par numérisation
d'information téléphonique
c'est une véritable révolution imaginer
le monde des années 80 il n'y a pas
internet
le seul moyen pour communiquer c'est le
téléphone filaire s'est occupée
et puis un jour des ptt vous offre
gracieusement un minitel c'est un petit
peu fort quand même la lumière là non ah
oui ptt orange france télécom à l'époque
ça n'existait pas encore ça s'appelait
les ptt poste télégraphe et téléphones a
avant tout été ensemble la poste les
téléphones tout c'était le thé la même
vie tel celui que vous aurez chez vous
du moins dans un premier temps se
présente sous cette forme cubique très
sobre de 25 cm sur 35 environ
cette grosse boîte s'ouvre sur le devant
pour faire apparaître un clavier tout
cet ensemble couplé avec le téléphone
permet d'interroger une banque de
données riche de tous les numéros d'ille
et vilaine ça c'est pour l'immédiat mais
dans l'avenir
il vous sera possible de disposer de
l'ensemble du gotha français
s'il parle de l'ille-et-vilaine parce
que c'était les premiers à disposer de
cette technologie révolutionnaire grâce
au minitel fini les annuaires ah oui
c'est vrai je suis là pour vous resituer
le contexte
à cette époque pour connaître le numéro
de téléphone de quelqu'un ou d'une
entreprise il fallait un gros bouquin
appelé à nevers dans lequel il y avait
tous les numéros de téléphone
j'en avais un blanc pour les
particuliers et un jaune pour les
entreprises il y avait tellement de gens
et d'entreprises qu'on ne pouvait pas
mettre la france entière dedans ça c'est
simplement paris en 1982 de i à z de a à
h
c'en est un autre c'était trop gros trop
lourd on n'avait pas forcément envie
d'avoir une bibliothèque des annuaires
de france près de son téléphone et qu'il
faut renouveler tous les ans en plus
alors on a édité des annuaires qui ne
recensait des numéros que par
département si tu t'attendais tu
trouvais que des vendéens c'était à
paris tu trouvais que des parisiens
si tu étais de l'ille-et-vilaine et ben
tu ne trouvait que d'éliminer les lignes
1 je peux faire tous les départements
comme ça ça c'est hyper lourd
et les mecs ils ivresse à chaque année
tous les abonnés des ptt recevait deux
annuaires bonjour l' indice carbone de
l'annuaire bref vous avez bien compris
que c'était pas très pratique
ces histoires d'annuaire bon ok il y
avait les renseignements le 12 mai
c'était payant oui oh ça va je sais on
n'a pas dépensé des millions juste pour
numériser des annuaires le minitel était
un projet lancé sous la présidence de
valéry giscard d'estaing président de
1974 à 1981 au revoir
on
en plus de montrer que la france était
un pays très innovant le but du jeu
c'était de vendre du minitel dans le
monde entier l'idée était de proposer à
tous un mix d'outils de communication
personnels de source d'information utile
de shopping à domicile et même de
services bancaires
mine de rien il ya 40 ans grâce au
minitel la france va découvrir quelque
chose qui sera développé beaucoup plus
tard internet
[Applaudissements]
nous avons essayé d'en faire un système
de communication c'est-à-dire que les
personnes ont la possibilité d'une part
de laisser des messages à d'autres
correspondants et également de dialoguer
entre elles à travers le système et ce
point un succès absolument considérable
puisque pratiquement la moitié des
personnes qui appellent le système sont
engagés dans des processus de
communication entre eux et ouais c'est
le début des forums des tchats et des
mails
bref on découvre une nouvelle manière de
communiquer pendant dix ans le minitel
connaît un succès grandissant
en 1993 on compte 6 5 millions de
minitel en circulation ont distribué
gratuitement les militaires jusqu'en
1987 ben c'est pas tactile consulter
l'annuaire était gratuit enfin les trois
premières minutes mais ce qui est
rapporté beaucoup d'argent c'était les
différents services proposés c'était
génial on pouvait consulter de chez soi
les horaires sncf le chiffre d'affaires
d'une entreprise les résultats du bac
l'argus de votre voiture la situation de
son compte bancaire et les petites
annonces pour accéder à un service
il suffisait de faire le 36 15 ça
connectait le minitel et ensuite ont
tapé le nom du service
on a connu jusqu'à 25000 36 15 et sans
doute le plus connu le 36 15 lula c'est
ce qu'on appelle à l'époque le minitel
rose une sorte de 4 qu'aucun que des
mots pas de son et des images ou des
dessins très rudimentaire à l'époque il
fallait avoir de l'imagination et du
temps et de l'argent chaque minute était
facturé et ça pouvait vous coûter cher
très cher pour une heure c'était 60
francs l'équivalent aujourd'hui de 15
euros on a vu des factures jusqu'à dix
mille francs de 1450 euros
non mes calculs ne sont pas faux il
correspond à l'inflation de l'époque
oui j'ai regardé sur internet pour
l'anecdote le patron de free xavier niel
a gagné ses premiers millions grâce au
minitel rose d'un jean n'a pas d'odeur
de 1994 à 1997 c'est l'apogée du minitel
mais on voit se pointer internet et les
connections illimitées sans frais
supplémentaires
une résolution d'écran bien meilleur des
connexions beaucoup plus rapide la fibre
c'est dix mille fois plus rapide
progressivement internet pousse le
minitel vers la sortie et le 30 juin
2012 marque la fin du minitel
finalement cette formidable invention
n'aura vu le jour qu'en france on a
essayé d'en vendre à l'étranger
la fin d'une époque et un changement de
carrière pour les trois techniciens en
charge du réseau minitel demain ils
travailleront sur internet
non sans une certaine émotion ouais ça
fait un petit pincement au coeur
là on va dérouler les opérations de
nettoyage non pour s'occuper l'esprit
parce que beaucoup d'émotion oui 36,15
connexion interrompue
définitivement